good morning my name is Andrea gay I'm
with the Andersons bedding products and
this morning on this very snowy day here
in Ohio I'm going to talk to you about
betting for thermal regulation and could
that actually work so to start off what
is thermal regulation well Miriam
Webster says thermal regulation is the
ability of an organism to keep its body
temperature within certain boundaries
even when the surrounding temperature is
very different so what is the lab animal
guide side while the guide says that
animals should be housed within
temperature and humidity ranges
appropriate for species to which they
can adapt with minimal stress and
physiologic alteration it also says to
maintain body temperature under a given
environmental temperature animals adjust
physiologically including their
metabolism and behaviorally including
our activity level and resource use so
what does that mean well what do you do
when you're cold usually we put on
sweaters we turn up the heat build a
fire when we're warm we take off our
coats turn on the air this is how we
change the temperature in our
environment so what about betting as you
can see here's an example of a cage that
has vetting in it and this is an
appropriate picture of about a quarter
of an inch of bedding not much for
thermal regulation the guide says the
purpose of bedding is to you betting is
to be used to absorb moisture minimize
the growth of microorganisms and dilute
and limit animals contact with the screw
show my spontaneously dig and many
substrates in the laboratory this
behavior comes from their ancestry in
the wild where they would forge for
seeds grain insects and other food to be
found buried in the soil or leaf litter
in their natural habitat
using more bedding than needed may allow
the animals to burrow for thermal
regulation but is not an appropriate
substitution for nesting material
betting is used as a latrine its
function and purpose is to absorb urine
as you can see here's a picture of
burrowing for thermal regulation in the
wild this animal has taken many
substrates straw grass leaves to line
and insulate his nest when facilities
are looking for bedding the thought of
what gives the best thermoregulation
never enters the conversation to perform
properly betting's need air to circulate
around the bedding to keep them dry dry
bedding equals no bacteria which means
pneumonia and a clean environment for
animals and staff facilities are
interested in bedding characteristics
such as does it look comfortable is the
bedding absorbent how is it for odor
control what are the contaminant levels
is the bed and easy to handle is it
dispensable what about waste removal do
we have storage for what we'll need
these are the questions facility
managers are looking at for answers
nowhere is thermoregulation mentioned in
looking for at specific vetting
properties corncob bedding absorbs from
the bottom up to do this minimal amounts
need to be used no more than a quarter
inch per cage this is important for
absorption looking at cob under
microscope it looks like a sponge cob
absorbs the urine and when the animals
move around the cage they are turning
the cob which then drives it out too
much per cage doesn't let the cod get
turn and the cod stays wet what betting
equals bacteria which promotes ammonia
would betting absorbs from the top down
generally it's recommended using
five-eighths of an inch per cage this
allows for maximum absorption
looking at wood under microscope it is
porous with wet betting it will allow
bacteria to grow which allows for
ammonia would betting also needs to be
changed more frequently recycled and
virgin paper beddings absorb from the
top down also it's recommended at three
eighths of an inch be used per cage for
maximum absorption paper is a very
absorbent and the cage changes are
extended too much paper being used will
allow for the mulch effect of being
unable to dry within the cage
environment again having wet bedding
will promote bacteria growth which leads
to ammonia production think of the cage
environment as a studio apartment they
eat sleep and urinate all in that one
space the animals do it all within an
environment that has air conditioning on
all the time or so it feels like to them
they are given a carpet to live on
giving them a thicker carpet makes no
sense for thermal regulation today's
current animal husbandry consists of
diet for nutrition water for hydration
and bedding for urine absorption and
ammonia control animals should be fed
palatable uncontaminated diets that meet
their nutritional and behavioral needs
animals should have access to potable
uncontaminated drinking water according
to their particular requirements batting
is used to absorb moisture minimize the
growth of microorganisms and to dilute
and limit the animals contact with
excretion to offer nesting material
would be encouraging typical normal
mouse behaviour studies have shown that
nests have several functions including
increasing litter survival regulation of
body temperature protection from a
predator shelter from colds or drafts as
well as being an inherent behavior
which makes nesting material a basic
need as nesting as a natural instinct
not a learned behavior at lower room
temperatures mice will start building
nests and huddling for resting and
sleeping this helps them keep warm and
behaviorally control their environment
it has been documented that abnormal
repetitive behaviors are also reduced
offering nesting material enhances the
well-being of lab animals as they are
able to perform more of their species
specific behaviors studies have shown
nesting is important for eliminating
stress and some abnormal behaviors this
is not enrichment but a basic
fundamental need currently enrichment
items are only required for singly
housed animals or breeders a lot of the
items that are offered today are toys
nesting material treats the animals are
able to forage and Hut's because of this
every rodent does not get enrichment
which is driven by budgets study
requirements behavioral or its lack of
importance in the lab in the wild
behaviors are very complex involving
unpredictably unpredictability along
with routines animals spend much of
their time searching for food and water
foraging for materials for shelter nest
building and my spilled very intricate
nests they spend their days dragon and
materials to build and line their nests
with this helps them with thermal
regulation and keeps them out of sight
of predators in the lab they are given
materials for enrichment that don't
allow for nuts building because of this
these materials often aid in eliciting
abnormal behaviors standard lab mice are
housed at temperatures that are
conducive to humans they are not able to
regulate their body temperatures by
controlling their environment as they
are not given biologically relevant
ariel's baron in a natural environment
in the lab which they have no control
over whatsoever studies have shown that
nesting material is a basic inherent
need from ice it eliminates a lot of
their stress abnormal behaviors and it
goes back to being in their studio
apartment the animals have a small space
with their physical needs met of food
water and their latrine the roommates
that haven't chosen and they are not
being given the opportunity to act out
their instinctive behaviors in the wild
as you can see here there's many
substrates brought into their nest at
lower room temperatures mice will start
building nests and huddling for resting
and sleeping this helps them keep warm
and behaviorally control their
environment in the lab as you can see
that brought it to different substrates
they have their bedding for the latrine
and they have a nest built and lined in
the wild the mice will dragen all sorts
of materials studies have shown that
might have a biologically inherent need
and show a strong preference to build
their own nests again when given
biologically relevant nesting materials
it's been documented that abnormal
repetitive behaviors are also reduced
offering nesting material enhances the
well-being of animals as they're able to
perform more of their species specific
behavior nesting material gives inferior
mice the opportunity to keep out of
sight and if needed escape from the
dominant mouse nesting material allows
the mice to control their environment
they not only perform their instinctive
behaviors but these materials also give
them control over the temperature of
their environment mites also altered the
quality of their nests in response to
ambient temperature the cooler the micro
environment is
the faster they will build a nest and
we'll make it very complex given two
different substrates at lower room
temperatures might start building nests
we all know that mice are highly highly
motivated to build their nests nests
have several functions that are
important to mice including increasing
litter survival regulation of body
temperature protection and shelter from
a predator mice will build nests in
response to temperature and in the wild
they live in nests not in a cage visible
to anyone in the room and their
neighbors and neighboring cages they
don't like to be seen as it's a
self-protective behavior today's nesting
program consists of one item generally
given for them to chew tomorrow is
better than nothing program could
consist of bedding material urine
absorption nesting material which allows
instinctive behavior an added nesting
material for thermal regulation mice
today in the lab are given a product to
nest with this product keeps them busy
chewing but it doesn't it does not
allowed them to build the dome type nest
that has been studied and documented
appropriate for thermal regulation 8
grams of nesting material had become the
optimum amount to regulate temperature
in a perfect world having two nesting
substrates would allow them to control
their temperature and their cage
environment again as you can see from
this picture they've woven a nest its
dome shaped and they've lined it
this is a simple answer to today's
enrichment programs basic nesting
material is added to the bedding as one
item in the animal husbandry budget
another nesting product is added for
thermal regulation this ends the
impoverished environment and makes the
unnatural cage environment more natural
by including biologically relevant
nesting material offering more than one
nesting material allows the animal to
mimic more of a complex multi-layered
nuts that their wild counterparts build
naturally this benefits all the mice in
the cage and allows for less stress cage
changes as an easy transfer material
into the clean cage can be done with the
dome type nest it promotes more of their
natural nesting behaviors of gathering
materials dragging them to the nest and
fluffing an unfurling they're also
carrying out a natural mouse behavior of
nest building to change their
environment for survival for facilities
to use a nesting material it has to be
convenient easy and economical most
facilities use some type of dispensing
system so the material needs to work
within that framework easy to dispense
having the bedding and nesting material
in one bag and bedding in neston allows
for the perfect amount per cage to
stimulate the natural instincts and
behaviors of nesting as well as perform
the important function of urine
absorption and have an invested in
getting the nesting material program is
a repeatable system the interest is in
richer cob is the perfect base batting
as it has a corn cob for absorption and
proven ammonia control it is nesting
material added to promote the nesting
instincts and behaviors for less stress
ative normal behaviors enrich acabei in
the construction of equality nests by
providing appropriate base nesting
material adding another nesting material
allows for the animals to insulate their
nest this aids and
regulation allows in the minute what
would be done in nature it also allows
them to build their dome type nest by
giving them enough material to build the
dome type nest for thermal regulation
and then allowing them to insulate it
it's clear that for Animal Welfare and
its studies have shown adding nesting
materials is not a luxury but helps the
study by reducing the variables added by
stress offering more than one nesting
material gives a choice to the animal
which empowers them and allows them some
control over their environment using
bedding and nesting materials as a base
batting program not only provides the
mice more control over their environment
but also allows them to regulate their
body temperature reduce abnormal
behaviors and end the impoverished
environment in the end a good management
program provides the environment housing
and care that permit animals to grow
mature reproduce and maintain good
health this provides for their
well-being and minimizes variations that
it can affect research results so in
short using the base bedding and nesting
material plus the added nesting material
for thermal regulation allows the
bedding to perform its function of
absorbing excreta not for nesting and
Burling or thermal regulation thank you
I appreciate you watching this talk and
I hope you all have a great day
I have a question